[Music]  I'm Rick Dalton it's my pleasure  then mr. Schwartz army mom put it down  that's your son no that's my stunt  double clip booth last night we bought  Avery Dalton double feature I'd love  that stuff you're too old to killing a  lot of kill him  [Music]  seems this world  oh you still drag guys go here you can  do anything you want  how'd you can actor wick TV cowboy  you're better than that  all right what's the matter partner it's  official old buddy has been here I am  flat on my ass I got the next door to me  I'm Sharon Tate I'm in the movie you're  in this that's me  I play Miss Carlson the class baking  [Music]  [Applause]  in this town I can all change  hey you're Rick [ __ ] Dalton don't you  forget it  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  you